verzichtet ist für mich keinen Weg Klima
muss mit Innovationen verbessert werden
und diese ganze verbotsdynamik bringt
uns genau zum Gegenteil wir wollen ja
nicht so in die Steinzeit sondern wollen
die Zukunft
da muss ich im Recht geben mit dem Wort
Zug kommt und dass wir innovativer
werden müssen
ich habe ein Problem mit dieser Klima
Hysterie ich glaube nicht dass Panik uns
dabei hilft bessere Entscheidungen zu
treffen in dem einen Tag sind wir in der
Redaktion müssen die nächste Ausgabe
planen am nächsten Tag bin ich in Berlin
und treffe mich mit einem prominenten
den wir für unsere heftigen am nächsten
Tag halte ich einen Vortrag ob in
München oder in Stuttgart oder in
Frankfurt
nach dem kurzen Einblick wäre das für
mich so eine Person die würde ich auf
der Straße
der würde nicht mal helfen habe aber nie
in Frage gestellt ob jetzt irgendwelche
klimatischen Entscheidungen oder sowas
gerade von mir als Einzelperson sowieso
irgendeine Auswirkung hätten auch als
Einzelperson kann man durchaus was
ändern es gibt andere die sind bereit
aus eigener Motivation heraus auf
irgendwas zu verzichten ich will es ihm
nicht verbieten zu verzichten ich will
mir aber auch nicht anhören dass mir
einschränken soll der will sein Leben
leben gut ist ja solange schadet
niemanden aber weißt du das halt ich
habe zum Glück keinen schlechtes
Gewissen dabei ich bin ein großer
Komfort Fan bin tatsächlich auch so ein
Mensch ich bin sehr gemütlich weil es
daran denke soll ich beantworten soll
ich Auto fahren ich denke auch lieber
ins Auto
Julien Backhaus ist der Klimaschutz egal
ähm mir ist Umweltschutz sehr wichtig
und ich will dass wir eine saubere Luft
haben und sauberes Wasser haben und
alles was dazugehört ich glaube aber
nicht dass ich durch mein Verhalten
irgendeinen Ausschlag entweder in die
eine oder in die andere Richtung machen
also wenn man wenn das jede Person so
sieht ja ich als Einzelperson kann ja
nichts unternehmen ja dann kann das
nichts werden wir sind heute Person
[Musik]
ich bilde mir ja immer noch ein dass ich
Arbeitsplätze schaffe dass ich
Gewerbesteuer in meiner Gemeinde zahle
dass ich caritative Projekte unterstütze
das kann ich ja alles weil ich als
Unternehmer aktiv bin und weil ich etwas
tue aber jemand der sich einfach nur
irgendwo festklebt der ist ja im
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes stehen
geblieben er will sich nicht
einschränken lassen das ist halt der
verteidigt seine Welt so wie sie ist ich
bin ja auch gerade irgendwie so meine
Unternehmung am grünen und ich denke mir
auch wenn ich da was mache und tue und
irgendwann größer bin dann kann ich ja
viel mehr Einfluss nehmen als mit der in
einem Vakuum Leben es gab tatsächlich
diese Protestaktion auf dem Schiphol
Airport in Niederlande wo Privatjet
sozusagen gekapert wurden und da haben
sich dann Klima Aktivisten vor
festgekettet deswegen habe ich
spaßeshalber mir aus dem Büro so eine
Pappe mitgenommen und habe damit Edding
drauf geschrieben also [__] you last Jam
weil ich das einfach finde das aber auch
albern mit dem Schild mein lieber kannst
deine Meinung an dem Punkt gerne für
dich behalten eigentlich nichts zu tun
beeinträchtigt werden immer nur die
Leute die wirklich zur Arbeit müssen und
er macht da so einen großen Heckmeck
drum also der dürfte sich das gar nicht
erlauben muss man dann gleich andere
Methoden so verurteilen und Julien no
Front klimaaktivisten sollten lieber
etwas erfinden im Zweifel dann verkaufen
so dass wir alle davon profitieren
können wir profitieren von daher ein
Welt oder nicht die politische Freiheit
versuche ich ein bisschen Aktivismus zu
betreiben dass wir eben nicht in diese
verbotsmentalität abdriften sondern dass
wir dieses freiheitliche Leben so wie
wir es uns ja erarbeitet haben dass wir
das fortführen und dass wir das auch
verteidigen ich bin auch ein Mensch ich
sage Freiheit und Vielseitigkeit ist
super wichtig diese extreme
klimaaktivisten sind nur eine einzige
Meinung und alles andere falsch also
wird nicht toleriert ist falsch
die reichsten 1% Schaden den Klima
doppelt so stark wie die ärmere Hälfte
und das was ich tue schadet niemandem
auf der Welt ist doch sicher nicht so
definitiv Emittenten die die wirklich
große Budgets zu verantworten haben wo
man darüber diskutieren kann sicherlich
dann mit Klimawissenschaftlern und so
weiter aber ich wenn ich von A nach B
Fliege tue niemandem etwas Schlechtes
damit das ist Quatsch also da gibt's ja
auch Statistiken zu die die obersten ein
Prozent machen extrem viel
Umweltschäden ich bin auch gerne mit dem
Flugzeug wenn ich zum Beispiel ins
Ausland muss unterwegs weil es schneller
geht nicht mehr um 40 sondern es geht um
extravagant und es geht darum dass er
irgendwie sein sehr sehr hohen
Lebensstandard den wir alle irgendwie
nicht teilen es ist albern überhaupt
privat jetzt für die klimaverschmutzung
verantwortlich zu machen weil der
prozentuale Anteil am Gesamtbudget so
unglaublich verschwindend ist ja ist
halt ignorant schon wieder ich würde
mein Leben nicht radikal ändern um
irgendjemand das Ziel gerade zu
erreichen ich hoffe dass wir radikal
mehr an der Innovation arbeiten
ich glaube die nächsten Jahre werden uns
alle überraschen wegen der technischen
Fortschritte die wir gerade machen
werden wir in fünf Jahren eine komplett
andere Welt haben wahrscheinlich schon
eine mehr oder weniger Klima neutrale
alles wird besser sein
wake up Julian wir sind im 21
Jahrhundert the last generation heißt
nicht ohne Grund so also ich würde Ihnen
sagen oder mehr Zucht zu fahren und das
ganze publik zu machen damit andere
Leute das auch sehen und das vielleicht
dann auch so umsetzen mein Name ist
Robert ich bin 31 Jahre alt wenn ich auf
den Klimawandel Blicke habe ich
Existenzängste aber Alsdorf Kind kann
ich auch bestimmte Dinge nicht
verzichten wie zum Beispiel auf das Auto
[Musik]
es wurden jetzt Leute gefragt von 25 bis
34 ne also das will deine Generation
fürs Klima ändern die Flop 3 Masken an
es überrascht mich nicht dass da so
wenige sind weil es halt das extrem ganz
ehrlich so illegalaktion oder diese
Extremsituation wie festkleben oder
Denkmale vernichten das ist doch nur
noch mehr Wut aus wenn ich halt an
Politik denke ich an einen behäbiges
langsames Konstrukt die Generation ist
er das illusioniert und er kennt ja
irgendwie ist es viel Kraftaufwand und
ich selber war auch in einer Partei da
habe ich einfach selber gemerkt
irgendwie das hat kaum Frucht gebracht
demonstrieren wir alle wurden da total
sensibilisiert deswegen also da hat
feines for future total viel Frucht
gebracht nur sind die Gesetze immer noch
Dickerchen
ich finde die Eileen ich bin 21 Jahre
alt ich habe schon fürs Klima
demonstriert aber jetzt schaue ich wie
ich eher im Alltag radikaler werden kann
ich bin 26 habe ich schon recht viel
fürs Klima wird gerne neue Wege finden
wo ich in meinem Leben radikaler
verzichten kann
jedes nach und ich will mehr Menschen
mehr wie Jesus ne dass ich aber auch
meinen Umfeld sich mehr an ihm
orientiert weil er war meiner Meinung
nach der größte Umweltschutz aller
Zeiten wer sind eigentlich meine
Vorbilder sind das meistens radikale
Person die wirklich für etwas stehen und
auch diejenigen die Veränderung bringen
weil sie Aufmerksamkeit erzeugen ich bin
gespannt
[Musik]
Weltreise haben wir über 86 Länder
bereits 100.000 Kilometer in der Welt
irgendwie hin und her gechattet aber
wenn du das Tages Nachhaltigkeit und
Reisen dennoch uns absolut wichtig
geworden über die letzte Zeit genau
beispielsweise kompensieren wir den
co2-abdruck unseres gesamten
Unternehmens wir haben eine nachhaltige
fashion brand wo wir einfach Plastik aus
dem Meer zu nachhaltiger Mode recyceln
deswegen versuchen
einfach die Balance zwischen Reisen und
Freiheit und auch Klimaschutz zu bringen
diese kompensationssache ah nein ich
finde es gar nicht mal schlecht wenn man
sein Gewissen beruhigt das sagt ja auch
irgendwas aus wenn du willst ein
bisschen flüchten aus deiner Realität
oder Deutschland ist zu langweilig wie
viel reisen so sagt dann z.B alle drei
Jahre fliege ich dann mal weg ist für
mich dann ein Highlight in meinem Leben
also wenn Sie alles wirklich so machen
super wenn ich mal wegfahre dann ist das
eigentlich nicht weiter als vier Stunden
im Auto warst du schon mal im Wald und
was so ohne Handy hast du schon mal
geguckt ne was um dich herum passiert
gestern waren wir spazieren die Vögel
Alter seine Gegend kennt man halt
irgendwann ja so ein Grand Canyon den
gibt's halt nicht bei uns in der Gegend
ne ich muss wirklich zugeben müsste ich
jetzt das Klima komplett aufs Reisen
verzichten also mir wird selber glaube
ich nicht gut gehen ich finde super
traurig und manchmal denke ich sogar so
eigentlich muss ich jetzt noch machen
bevor es vielleicht wegen solchen
Sanktion so teuer wird das gar nicht
mehr machen kann breiten wir auf Kinder
Link sein ja 1 2 6 6 6 6 next ja also
wenn ich das sehe wenn ich da jetzt
leben müsste um Gottes
kindische Reaktion meiner Meinung nach
der fährt halt gern dickes Auto
i love you also warte mal jetzt nach
links ich seh ja keinen Sinn das Bild
anzukleben bisschen von beidem auch da
wieder Aufmerksamkeit aber auch sowas
geschichtliches sollte halt nicht
beschädigt werden also überhaupt ist
radikale ist nicht so mein wenn ich so
mein Weg
[Musik]
radikal heißt ja eigentlich nichts
anderes als gründlich sie hat verstanden
dann würde ich auf jeden Fall sagen dass
es mir ziemlich wichtig ist radikal zu
sein
ich bin Maria ich war für den
Klimaschutz im Gefängnis und ich würde
es wieder Künstler das ist krass kann
ich nicht verstehen ich finde diese
radikalen Einstellungen so schrecklich
so ein bisschen dieses Märtyrer sein bei
der letzten Generation bin ich seit
Anfang Oktober und habe regelmäßig
blockiert zum Beispiel eine Pipeline
abgedreht ich war dabei jetzt sind
Feueralarm ausgelöst wurde im Bundestag
ich bin die letzte Generation sterben
wieder alle was bedeutet das und ich bin
dann letztlich auch noch München ins
gefängnisstadlheim gekommen und war dort
eine Woche in der Tierkreis finde sie
schaltet den Klimaschutz weil sie
einfach so viel Wut und Provokationen
Leuten aussieht aber andererseits glaube
ich dass man auch nicht alle Menschen
mit so sei dann Handschuhe anfassen
müssen sagst Klima ist auch schlecht
schlecht ja ist so man guckt sich
natürlich auch so ein bisschen um wie es
den anderen Blockade geht das kann ja
auch schon vor dass teilweise dann Leute
aufgefahren sind okay das Leute auf dich
drauf gefahren sind finde ich jetzt
krass sie schützt mich nicht indem sie
mich aufhält zur Arbeit zu fahren wie so
ein kleines Kind was dann stur ist und
sagt nur ich habe jetzt das gleich
keinen Bock mehr auf der anderen Seite
bin ich halt wieder auf dem Punkt dass
man halt Aufmerksamkeit erzeugen muss
weil sonst passiert halt nichts und ich
glaube so ist noch Leute die werden
provoziert dann sagen die jetzt erst
recht nicht ich scheiße jetzt aufs Klima
wir sehen waren im besten Zeiten 1,4
Millionen Menschen auf der Straße das
hat dann letztlich zu einem
verfassungswidrigen Klimaschutzpaket
geführt ich habe ein protestraining üben
wir jetzt wie man in einer Vokabel dann
von der Polizei weggetragen werden kann
also ich hätte jetzt niemals gedacht das
Klima Kleber sich so extrem vorbereiten
wichtig ist dass man selber erstmal Ruhe
ausstrahlt wenn man selber da so ein
Nervenbündel ist dann macht das den
Autofahrer auch eher aggressiv
es geht nicht weg
wir sind die Auto Nationen schlechthin
und ich denke davon müssen wir auf jeden
Fall wegkommen von diesem Gedanken dass
wir ewig mit dem individualer Verkehr
durchkommen können
es geht nicht ohne Auto wäre ich oder
wären wir aufgeschmissen individuell hat
sie gerade Individualverkehr gesagt ey
deswegen Fahrgemeinschaft ja es ist halt
nur so auf dem Dorf das äh der nächste
Bahnhof 16 km weit weg ist
in der Öffentlichkeit geben sie sich als
klim
a aber privat
[Musik]
Terrorismus und das darf auf gar keinen
Fall passieren ich finde da nimmt sie so
dieses Joch aus sich dass sie die
Retterin die jetzt da mit ihrer Gruppe
einsteht für uns alle und uns kann sie
aber nicht also es gibt einfach gar
keinen Sinn die Aktion der Klima Kleber
sind keine Demos sondern organisierte
Straftaten und ja stand jetzt sind
unsere Straßenbahn in vielen Fällen
rechtswidrig es gab ja bisher sehr
wenige Freisprüche warum gab es da
überhaupt frei Sprüche
ich habe für die erste Blockade eine
sehr hohe Geldstrafe bekommen und 881
das ist erstmal sehr schockierend wenn
man diese Briefumschlag öffnet und da
diese Zahl sieht weiß natürlich dass
solche Dinge vermehrt auf mich zukommen
werden eben weil jetzt noch viele
Strafbefehle auch stehen
das ist auf jeden Fall wert weil es geht
um nichts geringes als den Schutz
unseres Lebens und den Schutz
zukünftiger Generation
ich kann mir bessere wie gesagt bessere
Arten und Weisen vorstellen unsere
Generation zu helfen der Dialog wird
zwar angefacht aber irgendwie der hate
und der
Klima Ding lass doch einfach alle unser
Leben genießen und wird dadurch
irgendwie eher noch
das ist schon sehr beeindruckend dass
man das halt trotzdem macht und darauf
scheißt ich bin Erik in 30 Jahre alt ich
weiß dass ich was tun sollte das ist auf
lange Sicht um Leben und Tod geht weil
ich selber erlebt habe aber ich bin dann
zu bequem was zu ändern also die
Situation im Aartal hat mir halt noch
mal selbst spüren lassen was es bedeutet
wenn Klimawandel halt extrem wird auch
wenn ich jetzt nicht selber meinen Haus
verloren habe habe ich im Schlamm
gestanden habe da meinen Freunden
geholfen und halt auch ganz vielen
Leuten die da drumherum waren die nichts
mehr hatten auf einmal und dann hast du
mal gesehen was für eine Kraft die Natur
hat wenn jeder irgendwo einen sieht man
muss das tun und allein schon drüber
nachdenkt dann ändert sich auch was